you know every idea is like a little
seed that is inside me and I suppose
that I have many seeds and some of them
start to grow and unbothered me and then
because they become like an obsession
and then I know that I will probably
write about that
now what is the book going to look like
or what is the story going to be like I
I don't know if it's a historical novel
I will do the research if it's not if
it's just an idea of some kind I sit
down on January 8th and start writing I
write between 8 and 14 hours a day
sometimes so how long does it take if it
if the research takes very long I don't
even count it I I would say that in a
year I should have a book done now how
much work I have done before I don't
know a lot
I work with one thing at once writing
but I can be writing for example in
memoir and researching about Haiti to
write the island beneath the sea and
that's exactly what I did with my recent
book but in order to write the book it
needed a lot of research I had done two
years of research I thought I was ready
and they don't generally ape I realized
it was wasn't there yet and so I wrote
in between a memoir but I continued
researching for the book
well actually I started my first novel
the house of the spirits on January 8
1981 because I was living in exile in
Venezuela and my grandfather was dying
in Chile and I could not return to be
with him so I started a letter for him
that turned into the house of the
spirits my first novel and it was a very
successful book so out of superstition
and Kabbalah I started the second book
on the same date but that my life got
really complicated with book tours and
prayers and correspondence and fan
letters and you know it's complicated
and so now I have a foundation also I
have to run a foundation and family and
my office plus writing the way I do it
is very schizophrenic I divide the year
in half and the first half of the year
starting January 8th is my inner time
the time of writing is a quiet silent
time of solitude and then the rest of
the year I do what I have to do
the story I I love stories and I do
research let's say about for the my
latest book island beneath the sea I
research for this today Haiti and New
Orleans the Caribbean and then that
leads me to research about the American
Revolution and the French Revolution and
what was happening with the Pirates of
the Caribbean and it's like pieces that
I sort of put together and then I sit
down on January 8th with all this
research on all these pieces and I know
that I'm going to write about a woman
slave that's all I know
and I have sort of seen the woman I know
who she is now what's going to happen to
her her story
I don't really know it as I write it
starts off it starts to unfold and then
when the characters do things that that
are unexpected for me then I know that
the story has its own course is
furrowing and how do the other
characters come as I need them if I have
a slave of course I have I need a master
and I need their family and I need other
slaves and I need people who will help
the slave to find her freedom and I need
someone who was in love with her
so all that comes in the process
my desk is like like a you so I have my
computer and lots of dictionaries
because I write in Spanish and I live in
English and in the case of my latest
book everything happened in French in a
French colony so I have books in French
and I mean dictionaries in French in
English in Spanish and I worked like
that and then I have all my research
around me and my office has all the
walls covered with my first editions and
photographs of the people I love dead
and alive and that's it it's messy